darvish making start number 21 7-5 3.27
the era 115 and two-thirds innings
charlie blackman will stand into the
left-handed batters box as we get
underway padres playing a saturday night
home game one and two to blackman manny
backs up now playing basically the
shortstop position and the pitch is
taken on the outside corner at the knees
strike three call
so darvish punches out blackman one away
in the top of the first inning story was
not in the lineup last night for
colorado although he was originally and
they scratched him it was trade deadline
day he expected to be traded and wasn't
2-2 pitches lined to the right side nice
backhand pick by hosmer race to the bag
eric will win it and the side is retired
great defensive play over at first base
by hosmer and he gets a hand a one two
three first inning for you darvish with
a strikeout and some sparkling first
base defense after half an inning no
score padres coming up against marquez
airmon marquez for the rockies start
number 22 eight wins and eight losses
3.54 the earned run average and eric
hosmer will stand in
machado's really locked in right now and
he'll be a guy we have to
see how the rockies handle them eric
hosmer swings at a sinker and skies it
to left easy chance for connor joe
the long single does no damage we head
to the second no score and a catcher
elias diaz who also homered last night
coming up oh two swinging a miss that a
fast ball and he blew it right past
elias diaz for his second strike out of
the night
no runs a two-out walk to connor joe
he's left at first base and after an
inning and a half at petco no score
switch hitting catcher
victor caratini
a look back to second by marcus
3-2 to carrottini is a bouncing ball to
second brendan rogers on over to first
and the walk does no damage
he's got the swag chain going
and the jersey
here's charlie blackmon the leadoff man
charlie ground ball diving stop and
hillier will score
frazier dove looked up hilliard again
speed
in any sport so valuable
rogers with a ground ball to short
tonight
and blackman's rbi
ground out to second has put the rockies
in the lead and roger swings and drives
it to center field back goes grisham at
the wall it is over and out of here
another home run on the trip for brendan
rodgers his fourth and the rockies lead
it two to nothing
darvish four for 36 this year at the
plate
breaking ball from marquez swung on and
missed and darvish goes down
by way of the k first for
airmon tonight
one out frazier at second base and jake
crawlworth coming up
grounded out to second base in the first
o for one
high drive deep right field that's
headed towards the crowd zone
two run home run for jake cronin worth
his 15th of the year this game is tied
two to two
oh and he knew it too bah he knew it
watch the skip and the hop oh yeah
two-two the score as we move to the top
of the fourth inning
darvish had given up two runs in the top
of the third padres get two back in the
bottom of the third inning
and it's ryan mcmahon who leads it off
here for the roxa in the fourth
and a one-two pitch coming to ryan
mcmahon
[Applause]
got him
some high heat at 95.
strikeout number three for you darvish
tommy pham
is the hitter came up with the cardinals
marquez says no to one sign gets another
one quickly breaking ball swinging in a
miss and he gets fam
for his second strikeout of the night
trent grisham to hit for the padres
two strikes to grisham and he goes after
a breaking ball in the dirt swung on and
missed diaz with the throw down to first
and it's two strikeouts to begin the
fourth for airmon marcus
that'll bring up jurickson profar
against the angels six in a third
innings on monday night
four runs allowed three earned angels
got him for eight hits
mark is also fan eight in that game
pitch is swung on and missed and marquez
strikes out the side in the fourth
diaz is one of
three strikeout victims for darvish
1-0 breaking ball well hit the left
field going back fam it is out of here
touch him all time for elias diaz
a personal best 11th home run and the
rockies regain the lead three to two
so here's sam hillyard left-hand batter
manny's shift on the right side
two and two to hillyard with the manny
shift on in shallow right
pitch on the way from darvishan taken
for strike three fastball at the knees
and he punches him out that's four
strikeouts now for you darvish that'll
bring up german
pitch breaking ball is hit the center
field going back is grisham to the
wallets out of here
airmon marquez with a blast a dead
center field
into the bushes underneath the batter's
eye
another long ball for the rockies
they're up four to two
four to two rockies now top of the order
charlie blackman two and two to blackman
one out base is empty
and the pitch is swung on and missed
came with the fastball and strikes him
out
second of the inning and fifth of the
night for darvish
so two outs and the base is empty with
the very busy brendan rodgers coming up
another 0-2 see how he attacks rogers
this time darvish ready here's the pitch
and a swing and a miss
looks like maybe a splinter don't know
if we've seen one tonight but the third
strikeout of the inning for darvish
closes out the top of the fifth inning
not before the rockies hit two more solo
home runs including one by the pitcher
jeremiah marquez we are midway at petco
4-2 colorado darvish strikeout his
initial at bat
marcus delivers there's strike three
called a slider on the outside part of
the plate
now the left-handing third baseman
left-handed hitting third baseman ryan
mcmahon he's over two against darvish
tonight
two and two to mcmahon here's the pitch
from darvish and that is taken on the
inside corner at the knees strike three
call
mcmahon becomes the first rocky to
strike out 100 times this season darvish
punches him out that's seven for you
one away with story at second base and
cj crone coming up
three and two to crone with story at
second base starvish deals and the pitch
swung on and missed back-to-back
strikeouts
after the lead double by trevor story
and a really
nice job by darvish there he went 3-0 on
chrome and comes back to get his k
connor drew a walk in the second inning
4-2 rockies two outs here in the sixth
with story at second ground ball up the
middle and into center field for a base
hit story comes around to score connor
joe with a two out rbi hit five to
rockies
so the padres trying to answer back like
they did in the third inning
bring the potential tying run to the
plate and tommy pham
slowly airman works into the set the
pitch the 2-2 swaying and a miss on some
high cheese
out number two strikeout number six
pro
profar
the switch hitter has walked and struck
out
the 02
strike three called
profar can't believe it
jase tingler out of the dugout he just
was ejected from the game
airmon marquez strikes out profile with
the bases loaded
and that ends the inning
rio ruiz who started the first game of
the series
at first base will bat
for jolie shaw seen ending his night
two and two here it is to ruiz he takes
and on the outside corner strike three
called another k
for padre pitching here tonight no runs
a hit and a man left at third base
last chance to dance coming up head to
the bottom of the ninth in petco it's
the rockies five and the padres two and
nola will pinch it for craig stamet
to left field connor joe coming in
sliding can't catch it profile will
score it's an rbi single and the padres
pick up their third run
and adam frazier is the hitter
ground ball to second there's one on the
first inning ending double play game
ending double play
and the rockies hang on five to three
they've won two of the first three in
san diego